[Musique]
ce dont on va vous parler cette semaine
porte plusieurs noms fraude amoureuse
arnaque à l'amour arnaque aux sentiments
c'est essentiellement quand une personne
tombe en amour sur internet de quelqu'un
qui se fait passer pour un bon monsieur
ou une belle madame qui finit par
demander de l'argent
tobin tête intelligente je t'aime bien
voit plus clair le nouveau bus qui se
pense seulement que l'an dernier
8 millions en fraude au canada et c'est
seulement les faits
déclaré
combien d'autres vivent dans la honte de
s'être fait prendre que s'est envolé à
part l'argent laissé deux mois mais
c'est une descente aux enfers d'abord
financière
une très bonne pension il ya un bon
salaire mais caroline john en mai
commerce fait pas arrivé mais c'est bien
pire qu'un crime économique on va vous
montrer de quoi les fraudeurs sont
capables
de lavage de cerveau encore imiter une
forme de violence on s'est lancé sur la
piste honneur réseau d'arnaqueurs qui
aurait fait près de 51 aline
bonjour nous sommes coincés ici
marie maude denis bienvenue à enquête
certains parents ont peur que leurs
adolescents tombe sur de mauvaises
fréquentations
mais pour sylvain du gué ce sont les
amours de sa mère de 75 ans gisèle qui
ont bouleversé sa vie
plusieurs reprises mme agnès à le voir
ça gromard qui m'appelait pour me disait
tonton
manu chose qui va pas me faire faire des
transferts plaine des sports d'été des
petits montants le site plusieurs mille
1000 2000 3000 sylvain pose des
questions à sa mère me disait un ami me
fait un peu ils vont nous rembourser
les mii s'appelle jean pierre allinne un
soi-disant français de passage en côte
d'ivoire soit disant amoureux de gisèle
elle l'a rencontré il ya sept ans via la
messagerie d'un jeu en ligne je sais que
tout ceci qu a frôlé ce je le savais
mais depuis combien tu as à assas à
fonctionner c'est lors que je voulais
savoir je veux savoir qu'est ce qui
avait déjà été passées en côte d'ivoire
c'était seulement ma grosse inquiétude
larnaca l'amour a commencé aux nigériens
dans les années 2000 et s'était étendu
aux pays voisins et a particulièrement
pris racine ici en côte d'ivoire des
réseaux de fondeurs qui font des
victimes dans leur propre pays mais
aussi dans toute la francophonie jean
luc a déjà été l'un de ces fraudeurs je
vois ça le buttage et
avec l'acquis en piège
quand on tombe dans leurs griffes c'est
très compliqué de s'en sortir
sud de la france où elle réside gérard a
créé un site internet où il recense les
faux profils et recueille les
témoignages des victimes il les comprend
parce qu'il l'a vécu c'est pas le genre
de choses qu'on raconte facilement parce
que je vivais un divorce difficile
conflictuelles
c'était il ya dix ans gérard tombe sur
l'un des milliers de faux profils qui
gangrène les réseaux sociaux et lycées
de rencontre sans se douter que derrière
cette charmante femme se cache quelqu'un
comme jean luc dans son ancienne vie de
fraudeurs je la fais avec un profil
d'une femme où j'ai pris son nom il
cherchait aussi sa photo que j'aime et
et anciens se mapaï l'ayguade et anto
sur un super profil avec une superbe
blonde qui dit exactement ce dont on a
besoin
c'était le jeu de séduction il fallait
lui envoyer un message soit ça lui
répond comment tu vas je vais bien ok à
turbo de deux charmants et lui ça lui
qui répond maintenant
rhodia bel et bon la proviseure causé la
profession continue comme ça le
lendemain même s'ils ont eu beau c'est
une blague non mais on n'y retourne pas
ce qu'on a déjà trois ou quatre messages
et c'est parti
[Musique]
arrivent ensuite la promesse de
rencontre un grand classique de larnaca
l'amour on passe très rapidement au bout
de
quatre à six semaines à une demande de
billets d'avion pour venir en france
l'autre grand classique ce sont les faux
documents faux passeports faux documents
judiciaires et bien sûr les faux billets
d'avion comme celui qui a vu gérard ce
sont des scénaristes accomplir donc
après la belle prend l'avion étape
suivante
plus une nouvelle donc stress coup de
téléphone
lassila la douane qui vous appelle qui
le dit mais vous êtes bien l'ami de
manoel intel nous venons l'arrêté a été
en possession d'un objet en ivoire c'est
strictement interdite donc elle part en
prison comme en les aidant les jargons
c'est-à-dire format atx elle
trouver des astuces comment et
jouer avec les sentiments de ses clients
elle dix ans soit gp2 un par un jet
parent qui est victime sa d'une maladie
grave donc j'ai besoin d'argent donc et
puis de la douane ont passé la police de
la police on passe au procès et à chaque
fois il faudrait envoyer de l'argent
j'étais sous pression comme dans tout le
temps y maintiennent sous pression donc
quand j'ai quand j'ai pris conscience de
média à avoir comme ça c'était très dur
très dur parce que c'est un amour déçu
même s'il n'a jamais existé c'est de
l'argent perdu et c'est une
déconsidération
personnel cruel parce qu'on se dit quand
même avec les études que j'ai fait tu
t'es fait piéger bêtement comme ça c'est
dur à avaler quoi
la mère de sylvain gisèle a aussi été
dupé par un faux profil parce que le vus
sur une photo c'est ce qu'ils croient
c'est comme ça que c'est comme ça dans
sa terre dans la vraie vie cet homme
s'appelle stéphane il habite en france
s'appeler marica elle avait 30 ans elle
était de russie c'était la femme qui est
inaccessible ici quoi donc ce n'est en
dessous dans nos jeux stéphane a lui
même été victime d' arnaque à l'amour il
a raconté à la chaîne française m6
comment les fraudeurs ont volé ses
photos et ses vidéos pour leur ait
d'autres victimes comme gisèle il est
désormais un nouvel app hamas cullin
utilisés pour piéger des femmes
célibataires
gisèle d'un accès à son ordinateur à son
fils sylvain et il a un choc ben j'ouvre
skype c'est là que je vois des échanges
qu'elle a avec les fraudeurs
les premiers échanges ont été beaucoup
et fait jaser beaucoup énormément mama
pour connaître maman demandé énormément
de questions sur son entourage sa
famille ses enfants ses petits-enfants
il connaît ma mère l'eau comme sur la
pointe de ses doigts le clan luxe était
une femme qu'il net de ces paris qui
était seul qui était vulnérable il ya vu
cave un bon apport
l'arnacoeur il a une première du
première tâche c'est d'isoler sa victime
il faut absolument qu'il isole donc pour
l'isoler s'il a rencontré sur un site de
rencontres il va lui dire voilà on
adresse web watts a pour
autre réseau social de manière à avoir
une relation
publique - à deux îlots isolés prenant
il lui disait tout ce qui se passe quand
moi et toi si notre amour à nous deux il
faut que ça reste secret
comme comment il ya charme il lui disait
je pense des mots tels que marc jamais
entendu d'un homme probablement
ce qui là qu'il ne la cherche hippiques
qui est qu'elle aimait entente gens
comme tu es belle je t'aime tu es mon
amour
textos et messages matin midi soir une
fois entrés dans leur coeur les
fraudeurs prennent lentement le contrôle
de toute la vie de la victime maman
avant de dessiner de tous a donné 500
types de cartes de guerre caisses
populaires de ni son ni de facebook a
donné son nip de tous ces camps qui
avaient accès à tout tout tout tout
c'est ça qu'il faut que les gens
comprennent quand on est dans un état
amoureux surtout au début c'est de la
folie on est dans un état second donc on
est beaucoup plus malléable
puis un moment donné m 10 6 et 20 août
ses transactions look j'ai fait le j'ai
reçu j'ai passé des nuits des nuits à 10
pc y en avait des tonnes j'en revenais
pas mais je me rends compte que c'est
endetté avec les gains des cartes de
crédit qui sont passés la dame sont des
cartes de crédit sur des marges de
crédit d'un compte ici qui aura qu'une
faillite qui a été fait
après ça je me raconte une emprunte de
l'argent des gens à son entourage c'est
ça ça peut être des cousins des cous
enel ça pour être des amis je faisais
des termes que jamais je vois utiliser
j'étais folle des carrément folle de
faire ce que tu ne t'attends
sylvain a additionné les montants c'est
un désastre soixante et dix mille deux
ans
moi ici j'ai trouvé avec officiellement
avec des reçus cinquante mille dollars
gisèle n'est pourtant pas riche
mas une personne très travaillante c'est
une personne qui travaille dur dur et a
travaillé comme
serveuse dans un restaurant
caissière
[Musique]
j'appelle la police la police de sa
localité pilot en transferts un agent de
police ce sous communautaire de sa
localité choteau geek madame nathalie
langevin qui prend le dossier en charge
nathalie langevin et policières à
châteauguay comme aujourd'hui elle se
rend souvent rencontré des victimes de
fraude à l'amour dans sa municipalité
pour leur expliquer ce qui se passe dans
leur ordinateur mais c'est un problème
épineux est compliquée
et de bras m'en tombent et l'eau parce
que on n'y en a pas de levier
d'intervention nous comme policier puis
il était pas question pour ces
personnes-là d'un espoir porté plainte
il se voyait pas ni sur la victime de
quelque chose il était complètement pris
sous l'emprise
d'un risotto beau leur dire leur montrer
des des témoignages sont complètement
pris dans le filet
je lisais les textos tout ce qui se
disait entre eux qui que je voyais que
elle le considérait vraiment comme son
amoureux
comme son homme puis qu'ils étaient
prêts à faire n'importe quoi pour lui
c'est le jeu dijon source de cause là je
vais je vais faire quelque chose avec
sosh peux pas je peux pas la laisser
dans cette détresse là
sylvain va se battre pour tenter de
sauver sa mère gisèle
si vous pensez qu'il ya juste des gens
peu informés ou pas très dégourdi qui se
font avoir vous allez avoir une surprise
après la pause parce qu'on va vous
parler de l'histoire de christian un
enquêteur de la grc qui s'est fait avoir
avec des conséquences dramatiques
tu connais bcbe
il s'est fait avoir on a le droit d'être
humain
pour bien les gens ça peut paraître
complètement absurde de donner de
l'argent à un amoureux ou amoureuse
qu'on n'a jamais rencontrés en personne
mais quand on se plonge dans l'histoire
des victimes on s'aperçoit à quel point
les fraudeurs ont réussi à atteindre ce
qu'elle avait de plus fragiles en elle
[Musique]
andré bouchard pense à une escapade à la
campagne avec son ami christian
bonneville on prend avec monde hip hop
pop octobre a menacé m
c'était il ya quatre ans mais andry se
souvient très bien de la détresse de son
ami ce jour là
en arrivant labo christian sans vos
supports de la clôture puis il ya un
cheval qui le regardent sens bien avec
lui
pisi côté flatres pipe et plan mehdi
plan
cliquer sur bonneville jeunes
soixantaine venait de prendre sa
retraite comme enquêteur à la grc des
amis en commun l'ont présenté à andré
pour qu'ils l'aident andré et vétérans
des forces armées et fait du bénévolat
auprès de ses frères et soeurs en
uniforme qui ont besoin d'écouté garde
demain matin que sa joie de chez vous on
prend un tournant sans ça prendra le
temps que ça prendra
j'ai besoin de savoir qu'est-ce qui se
parle d'intérêts quand andré se rend à
la maison de christian il constate que
son ami vit dans la pauvreté et sa
maison est épouvantable
j'ouvre à le frigidaire pour du lait
puis à la joue sur du lait beach café
la première chose qui me présente après
le café c'est l'album de mariage de sa
femme il était fier de son mariage était
fier de sa femme
il s'en est occupé pendant 4 1
christian bonneville était très affecté
par le décès récent de sa femme mais
andry sent qu'il ya autre chose je
voyais qu'il y avait problème financier
puis tu peux pour paris que le phare
acte lourd mais je ne savais pas les
paiements tant sur la maison les
paiements tôt sur le pick up qu'est-ce
qu'il ya un bon revenu
pierre-yves pour sexy le convient
il me présente aux libyens
/ photo
qui olivia a vient de l'europe à 38 ans
est intéressé que moi j'ai investi de
l'argent avec elle dans son salon de
coiffure garde à m'envoyer des
certificats comme de quoi que j'ai j'ai
investi labos qui tout avait l'air vers
olivier / photo un moment donné j'arrive
y est en sng avait gênante matoto match
sera contre islam là
andré suggère à christian de demander à
ses anciens collègues policiers de
vérifier le courriel de son amoureuse
fallu vérifier voir si bon de courir
pendant ce temps à montréal
silva du guily les messages entre sa
mère gisèle et son fraudeurs les mots
doux on fait place à la manipulation et
aux menaces
violence très fort parce que c'est des
menaces puis il lui dit souvent si tu ne
fais pas ce que je veux que tu fasses
jeunesse se servir à répétition
[Musique]
oh
il à nouveau ma mère qui pleure non non
non j'en vienne ne me fais pas ça je
t'aime jean-pierre
[Musique]
donc moi c'est une forme de violence une
relation amoureuse qu'elle soit virtuel
où qu'elles soient dans le monde réel
c'est une relation amoureuse carmen
il y à peu d'études sur larnack
amoureuse mais claudine thibaudeau
intervenante chez sos violence conjugale
nous éclaire malheureusement quand on
parle de situation comme il l'objet de
votre reportage on s'arrête aux
comportements de violence économique on
s'arrête au fait que la personne
soutirent de l'argent mais il n'ya pas
que de la violence économique dans ces
relations là il ya beaucoup de violence
psychologique de manipulation de
violence émotionnelle
de s'organiser pour que l'autre personne
se sente responsable se sentent obligés
ou même l impression que c'est de sa
faute que l'autre est mal pris donc de
devoir quelque chose donc c'est très
complexe comme comme situation et ça
fait en sorte que
on devrait pas s'arrêter simplement à la
question économique parce que ça fait en
sorte qu'on ne comprend pas à tauriac
c'est une incompréhension de voir un
proche
se laisser aller comme son seul essai
violente et se décide minuit se laisser
perdre là-dedans c'est ça ressemble
beaucoup à à quelqu'un qui tombe dans la
drogue ou dans l'alcool ou dans le jeu
je dirais que ça ressemble beaucoup à
son et gisèle va tomber très bas on a
retrouvé gisèle d'un bâtiment comme moi
aux diabétiques non parce que elle avait
cessé d'acheter ses beats kama à la bcc
d'installer menthe et convenablement
lavé pu les
listes ou qui servait à principalement
sa survie je vous dirais que ce secret
blu est à mes yeux amont car les dents
les plus crapuleux
parce que les gens que j'ai vu est
victime de ces crimes là était
complètement anéanti complètement
détruits
à la même période christian bonneville
vit aussi une descente aux enfers il est
au pied du mur il a tout donné à olivia
elle doit arriver le vendredi suivant
le morguier m'appelle pour me dire tu
mens tu as raison je me serais pas moi
qui si on finit par réaliser qu'il s'est
fait fraudé et qu'olivia n'est qu'un
mirage
son monde s'écroule il doit relier dans
rues d'auch et d'un wii party il paye
appui d'hypothèques de la maison qui
camion de déménagement et ennemi le
vendredi
ambri passe en mode solution et trouve
une aide financière d'urgence pour son
ami il viendra le chercher demain matin
christian l'attendra par fatigue je vois
t'accueillir de même atteint cette année
mais j'arrive le matin puis ça répond
pas
ce que j'ai pensé oh non
je pose est rien je descends du village
even police là est ce qu il était avec
moi d'un confrère de la grc qui je pense
à vos poubelles matin
on est monté à maison tu le vois dessus
et accrochez
[Musique]
avait laissé une lettre de suicide
il y avait des tireurs tout était là
pour me sauver la vie merci parce que tu
as fait pour moi mais là c'est trop
sans même chercher
l'eau ça fait mal puis j'ai mal
des gens qui vont jouer leur des
manipulateurs qui vont jouer il ya des
escrocs qui vont jouer 2
en attendant on parle des bonnes
personnes et le cadran comme le monde
christian n'est pas le seul que larnaca
dessus et nous épluchons les rapports du
bureau du coroner du québec des sept
dernières années résultat ces suicides
d'hommes âgés entre 18 et 63 ans québec
dans plusieurs cas le passage à l'acte
est directement liée à des menaces les
fraudeurs profitent de la confiance et
de l'intimité qui se crée avec la
victime pour capter des images
sexuellement explicites et les faire
chanter il paraîtrait que de 7 à 2
heures dans la nuit
avec le top 6 le jeune mario policiers
certains articles c'est son ordinateur
là est ce qu a réussi à suivre les
transferts de christian jusqu'en côte
d'ivoire mais c'était impossible d'aller
plus loin la réalité c'est que c'est une
fronde est en national puis les suspects
sont pour la plupart du temps à
l'étranger c'est souvent des dossiers
qui sont malheureusement je voudrais
fermi parce que possibilité de procéder
à des arrestations on veut en matière de
ressources c'est quelque chose qui est
possible un haut gradé de la police
ivoirienne nous a confié que le canada
demande très peu souvent de l'assistance
pour résoudre des dossiers de fraude 17
demandes seulement l'an passé
mais s'il verts refusent de croire que
ceux qui arnaquent sa mère ne sont qu'en
côte d'ivoire
citron il faudra volume donné l'option
d'aller faire une transaction ou d'aller
acheter quelque chose
et c'est eux ils envoient directement à
une adresse c'est comme si mon qui sont
ici
l'intuition sylvain dubé était bonne on
est en route pour les vies parce
qu'après la pause on va se plonger dans
une enquête de la sûreté du québec soit
présumé les autres fraudeurs qui des
bases est ici dans la région de québec
et en côte d'ivoire
fruit d'un portefeuille de l'individu on
a sorti trois cartes de crédit ou non
mme amara dans le portefeuille
pour une fois deux trois cartes de
crédit
[Musique]
palais de justice de québec on est allé
chercher les documents sur une enquête
de la sq qui vise à imprimer raison d'
arnaque harkis étaient actifs ici dans
la région de québec jusqu'à l'an dernier
tout a commencé avec deux femmes la
région de lanaudière qui ont envoyé des
dizaines de milliers de dollars par la
poste à une adresse située juste
derrière moi dans cet immeuble à lévis
mais bien avant le début de cette
enquête policière sylvain du gui mener
son combat pour tromper le robinet aux
fraudeurs de sa mère un combats sur
plusieurs fronts
je passais à maintenant dans un fauteuil
assis à faire des téléphones d'assez de
chercher pour trouver une manière que ça
arrête puis que yann et piqué plus de
contacts avec les fraudes avec ma mère
fait tout à fait de dépêcher faire des
apl trouver des solutions trouver des
gens qui peuvent aider sur la crèche
puis sinon ça marche mieux que ça je
promets que d'abord il s'attaque aux
entreprises qui font des transferts
d'argent des deux principales qui ont
été plus majeur pour dans le coma
c'était la compagnie qui sait peut-être
boisse tenue
ils m'ont edwards j'ai essayé avec un
monogramme ça peut marcher rien du tout
même si money gram est un service offert
dans tous les bureaux de poste canada
une société fédérale pas moyen d'agir
pour les proches on peut valoir que
c'est comme c'est vraiment ma marque il
faut qu'il fasse la plante pic moi j'ai
aucun pouvoir là dessus postes canada
n'a pas daigné répondre à nos demandes
d'explication ouest ont eu lieu ont été
beaucoup plus coopérant ou estonien j'ai
réussi à le mettre sur liste noire un
peu plus faire de transaction de cotonou
il faut dire que western union a dû
nettoyer les écuries en 2007 aux états
unis un recours collectif intenté par
des victimes de fraudes a mis en lumière
une vaste corruption dans ces services
financiers en afrique l'entreprise a dû
rembourser près de 600 millions de
dollars aux victimes
sylvain essaie aussi de colmater la
fuite d'argent la source nathalie
langevin l'aide dans ses démarches
on est fait des démarches auprès des
anciens bancaire pourtant garder l'eau
arrêtez de 2,2 d'autoriser ces
transferts d'argent l'eau sensibiliser
ceux dans l'eau y est tout l'argent
qu'elle est sortie aujourd'hui on a la
preuve prévoir de tout doute que c'est
destiné où la fraude est chez desjardins
à sa caisse populaire on m'a répondu
monsieur dugué
l'homme la discrétion pour nos membres
est très importante chez desjardins on
ne peut pas vous répondre à aucune
question
mais on va prendre vos commentaires
en ligne de compte mais on ne répond à
paris
desjardins nous a dit qu'elle ne peut
pas empêcher ses clients de faire ce
qu'ils veulent avec leur argent
s'ils veulent faire une découverte dans
les documents de sa mère une note
manuscrite avec un nom qui lui dit rien
espoir kouassi
[Musique]
retour à lanquais de l'est ce qu on suit
que deux femmes la région de lanaudière
qui a envoyé des dizaines de milliers de
dollars par la poste à cet immeuble de
livres maintenant la police veut savoir
qui reçoit l'argent alors il on voit un
policier qui établit comme un facteur
porter une enveloppe à l'intérieur de
laquelle il ya 200 dollars en comptant
et sur les billets de banque la police a
mis une poudre invisible c'est une femme
qui ouvre la porte qui prend lé
enveloppe et une heure plus tard les
policiers perquisitionnent aux loges
il retrouve les enveloppes d'argent sur
la table de cuisine est un homme de 37
ans espoir kouassi que de la poudre sur
les mains la poudre qui était sur les
billets de banques vont saisir ces
appareils électroniques et
éventuellement de trouver des messages
avec des victimes des présumés complices
ils vont retrouver des bordereaux
d'expédition de colis et des photos de
piles d'argent comptant
je m'appelle
sûreté du québec qui dit
monsieur dugué
c'est une bonne nouvelle que j'épouse
annoncé la police a aussi trouvé autre
chose c'est quoi si fluide en
portefeuille de l'individu ou de sorties
trois cartes de crédit ou non ma mère
dans le portefeuille
une pas deux trois cartes de crédit et
quand ils ont ramené le matériel
informatique
au bureau ils ont découvert les
conversations avec ma mère
en analysant le matériel informatique
d'espoir kouassi et de ses présumés
complices la sûreté du québec trouve une
cinquantaine d'autres victimes partout
au québec des hommes et des femmes qui
dans certains cas ont perdu toutes les
économies d'une vie la fraude alléguée
s'élève à plus de 2 millions de dollars
c'est en moyenne 50 mille dollars par
victime
avec sa conjointe et un autre complice
espoirs kouassi est accusé de fraude ils
attendent tous les trois leur procès
donc pour moi c'est arrestation lol ça a
été une joie immense
selon l' enquête policière qui reste à
être testé au procès voici partager les
profits de la fraude avec plusieurs
complices en côte d'ivoire dont français
cet été et jean marcel et logne sur
leurs réseaux sociaux il semble mener
des vies de stars notre collaborateur en
afrique a retrouvé jean marcel et lognes
aujourd'hui
l'homme a tenté de faire croire qu'il
était dans le commerce de voitures avec
espoir kouassi mail enquête policière le
relie à au moins une dizaine de victimes
québécoises dont une dame de 84 ans à
qui il aurait conseillé de tuer son mari
pour recevoir l'assurance vie aucun des
présumés complices de kouassi en côte
d'ivoire n'a été accusé de quoi que ce
soit
pour transférer de l'argent ses présumés
complices en côte d'ivoire et sports
kouassi aurait recruté une douzaine
notariés et de québécois d'origine
ivoirienne des gens qui avaient à la
fois un compte de banque ici et en
afrique vous allez comprendre pourquoi
après la pause parce qu'on est à les
confronter un couple qui a participé au
stratagème et on n'a pas du tout eu
l'accueil auquel on s'attendait
et là je je suis tombé des nues ce type
est une
caisse elle m'a toujours dit que espoir
fait des affaires
et qu'il a des parasites
[Musique]
la théorie de l'enquète de la fqc
qu'espoir kouassi aurait dirigé un
réseau de fraudeurs qui travaillaient
simultanément ici et en côte d'ivoire
les complices qui aurait conversé avec
les victimes qui seraient en afrique
tandis qu'ici espoirs kouassi aurait
fait circuler l'argent
pour cela espoirs kouassi compter
notamment sur un couple de lévis
récemment immigrées de côte d'ivoire
dont l'homme possède aussi une pharmacie
à abidjan nous voulons obtenir leur
version des faits il nous ouvre
rapidement et rice a connues et était
koffi accepte de nous parle à la caméra
souvenir pour avoir une certaine
sécurité au niveau familial et pour nous
mêmes et pour leurs efforts son épouse
raïssa connaît explique qu'elles sont
arrivés au québec elles n'offrent qu'une
seule amie christelle seulement la
conjointe d'espoir kouassi elle m'a dit
que son conjoint fait des affaires ici
qu'il est étudiant mais qu'il a une
entreprise qui est déclarée il m'a dit
aussi que le espoir était d'une famille
très aisée au camp d'ivoire
espoirs kouassi a besoin de transférer
de l'argent en côte d'ivoire mais en
même temps monsieur koffi madame koné
ont besoin de rapatrier leurs économies
au canada et à partir d'un code pour
2018 mon épouse et moi nous avons émis
l'idée de nous acheter une maison
ils doivent transférer convertir
l'équivalent de 40 mille dollars
canadiens pour une mise de fonds pour
leur maison de lévis pour envoyer 40
milles de là c'est un peu difficile et
puis ça va coûter énormément de frais
quand on passe par les institutions de
transfert d'argent
l'offre de poissy et donc alléchante il
ne se méfie pas de lui puisqu'il est
étudié en science politique à
l'université laval quand tu es me voir
hier fait venir son enfant au canada
pour étudier avec un statut d'étudiant
c'est qu'à la base déjà les parents qui
sont qui sont des étés niveau social
ca c c'est le premier point
c'est quand même un élément pour nous
aussi qui peut justifier que ce bonhomme
là
puisse avoir autant d'argent
pendant plusieurs mois monsieur koffi
accepte près de 40000 dollars venant de
kouassi au canada à chaque versement les
complices de kouassi dont francis tt se
présentent à la pharmacie du docteur
koffi à abidjan et récupère l'équivalent
en devises locales nous regrettons
totalement ce qui s'est passé nous avons
été embarqués là dedans quelque chose
qu'ils ne ressemblent pas
honnêtement j'ai jamais pensé à la
jamais jamais jamais et puis en
septembre 2020 live qui débarque chez
eux je descends y avait à peu près une
dizaine de personnes des policiers
qu'est ce que je fais
et il me tend des papiers je m'excuse
mais au fait tu as pu reid
donc je suis parti
à 6h et - interviews et c'est de là bas
c'est là bas j'ai appris
que s coiffé du comptage
le broutage c'est le terme utilisé en
côte d'ivoire pour décrire les fraudes
amoureuse raïssa connaît et amené au
poste de police et là je je suis tombé
des nues j'ai tapé doh que seulement
toujours dit que l'espoir fait des
affaires
et qu'il a des parents hésitent et les
policiers m'ont montré les photos
des personnes l'un d'eux qu'ils se
soucient citer
qu'eux on était comme complice je n'ai
pas
espoir kouassi se serait servi d'au
moins dix personnes dont madame konin
pour faire des transferts d'argent
aucune d'elles n'a été accusé jeudi
quelque chose qui va vous blessez
m'aider à nouveau on n'est pas canadien
aux noix
vous voyez donc ne peut pas se permettre
de venir dans un pays et puis de faire
des choses comme ça on ne peut pas
comprendre qu'on puisse se retrouver
dans une histoire d'une bouteille on est
victime dans ce dossier
monsieur koffi vu que ce soit clair les
arnaques amoureux sont tout aussi
socialement inacceptable en côte
d'ivoire qui si on n'est pas nous sommes
désolés je suis profondément touché et
je voudrais mais joindre à toutes ces
familles et la cour
mais qu'il ya encore une fois devant
tous ceux qui prêtaient que vit-il
monsieur koffi a renoncé à beaucoup de
choses dans son titre de pharmaciens
pour s'établir ici
je ne voyage qu'en qu'ils soient
contents d'avoir osé voire ya maintenant
ce sera plus le cas que dit impatient
mais attend plus il est noir mais il les
voit rien c'est un bouteur
comprenez que si c'est compliqué pour
nous et ça ça ne favorise pas notre
réception
[Musique]
pour sylvain la joie d'apprendre
l'arrestation de poissy il y a un an a
laissé place à la déception depuis
peu près maintenant tout était
tranquille les fraudeurs communication
avec elle puis le bain malheureusement
c'est ça en mai
[Musique]
nous l'accompagnons chez sa mère gisèle
où la police viendra prendre une
nouvelle déposition
mon plus grand souhait ce serait que ça
avec ses murs ses preuves le pam a donné
ce matin qu'on soit capable de retracer
quelqu'un avec l'enquêteur de la sécu
silva va découvrir que sa mère envoie
encore de l'argent à son fraudeurs
en côte d'ivoire personne a été arrêtée
même s'il a exclu leur a transmis leur
enquête la personne qui donne vie au
fameux jean-pierre court toujours il
faudra savent qu'ils ont un contrôle sur
une personne pis ils en seront
ils en seront pas que ça cesse assez
c'est assez décourageant à 26 kitty nous
demandons à sylvain si sa mère
accepterait nous rencontrer il en doute
mais il fera de messages
en attendant à québec il y a quelqu'un
d'autre que nous devons absolument voir
pour ce reportage
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur kouassi bonjour je
m'appelle marie maude denis je suis
journaliste à la télévision de
radio-canada et j'aimerais vous parler
du dossier de fraude larnaca la meuse
pourquoi
vous voulez pas à discuter j'ai pris
connaissance
de différents éléments du dossier de
justice
la question qui me vient c'est pourquoi
vous faisais ça mais moi je veux laisser
mon jeu ok mais ce serait pas parce que
tu es un peu
bien sûr qui en a combien de temps
vous voulez vous voir
oui ok mais est-ce que vous avez
l'intention de rappeler tout à l'heure
ok est ce que ce serait possible de se
rencontrer aujourd'hui non ok pourquoi
pas un fait nouveau volet l'entretien
c'est moi qui vous souhaitez quelque
chose dont moi je vous dis ok mais
est-ce que vous avez l'intention de le
faire je vais vous rappeler que oui
c'est parce que leurs applis et
j'aimerais j'aimerais simplement savoir
laquelle d'élèves conseil d'accor merci
mettons fin au suspense il ne nous a
jamais rappelés par contre de retour à
montréal nous avons une surprise
j'ai hâte que cette histoire le fu ying
gisèle la mère de sylvain accepte de
nous rencontrer nous respectons son
choix de ne pas montrer son visage en
étant l'une
d'entre elle m'écrit
encore jean-pierre on demande à gisèle
de provoquer une conversation
[Musique]
moustapha
à coups de cherry et de mon amour il
demande à gisèle d'ouvrir un compte de
banque
[Musique]
et lui procurer une carte bancaire
ok
cette
maladresse
gisèle nous est sûr que cette fois ci
elle ne le fera pas tu es tu vraiment en
amour mais maintenant avec mais j'étais
tout seul
ge energy jeunes séparer d'un homme de
37 ans que je suis arrivé
et puis à force de jouer avec rue89 beau
même je tombe bien en amoureux j'étais
vraiment vraiment
[Musique]
puis avec lui cité comme inclus
j'oubliais même mes amis j'oubliais même
ma famille sur les entrefaites le
fraudeur insiste pour qu'elle envoie une
photo de la carte bancaire c'est clair
c'est quoi le nouveau message
je t'aime vraiment je m'excuse pour
toutes les erreurs du passé ça me fait
mal
de penser que j'ai donné tout ce que si
j'avais gagné dans ma vie j'étais
longtemps lors tous les nuits je
pleurais j'étais longtemps que je me
disais
tu fais quelque chose comme ça mais je
me suis longtemps gisèle est formel
c'est la même voie qu'elle entend depuis
des années qu'est-ce que tu en voilà à
part l'argent
la somme de moi même
puis ma confiance j'ai perdu
ma fierté ce feu après que tu tout souci
ce que tu as fait
que des blessés des enfants lapin
c'est beaucoup pour moi c'est pourquoi
t'es pas capable de couper les ponts
on dirait j'ai besoin encore de il parle
je suis pas pourquoi pour parce que
c'est le je les aime comme gelée mais
avant nous c'est comme
c'est pareil comme je pas capable de me
défaire le lui dit jean-pierre celui
tapé jean pierre louis
est ce qui existe chez elle non pas
vraiment
maintenant je sais
j'en crois pas ça mais c'est un c'est un
gros fléau c'est un gros gros fléau
québec et si on veut juste la peine de
regarder dans son entourage en plus
surpris
comme beaucoup de proches de victimes
d'arnaqués l'amour silva s'est battus
contre un ennemi invisible
il a été confronté à un système qui ne
pouvait pas grand chose pour aider sa
mère mais malgré tout il ne la laissera
pas tomber parce que c'est ma mort
[Musique]
on
puis je pense que
et l'endroit à cette protection
d'un doigt ce que quelqu'un fasse les
formes
[Musique]
de sédières pas toujours
je veux mentionnons en terminant qu'on a
mis des informations complémentaires et
des ressources en lien avec notre
enquête de cette semaine sur notre page
web c'est tout pour nous au nom de toute
l'équipe merci beaucoup d'avoir été l'un
venu nous la semaine prochaine pour une
autre enquête
[Musique]